i'll do one more one more random
random challenge ooh damiano's defense
okay ooh what country is this australia
down under opening requests
i still want to play a scotch scotch is
the very top of the list
i can't play scotch against b6
let's play this
play bishop g5 interesting move
preventing this this is actually an
interesting opening for
for bullets because a lot of people
pre-move e6
i guess black's just trying to play a
hippo
hungry hippo
hmm
i kind of want to have some fun
this is rated blitz let's have some fun
this is a terrible move
but it looks fun the idea is after it
takes i give away another bishop
and then i have some fun
i'm probably gonna regret this
but i can't i can't resist it's too much
fun
it might actually be good though too i
don't know
it's probably not i've just lost two
bishops
i have a majestic night
maybe soon to be another majestic night
all i have to do there's a few
winning ideas
i'll start with this
so i'm i'm down two bishops but
i'm close to meeting i'm really close to
meeting
that was a good move
uh
let's attack
oh look at this
this wins a queen
and i'm not even losing my own queen
because
this is the only oh wait a minute
it's not the only legal move
i forgot about that
oops so i can play knight g5
i have knight g5 queen e6
i could end up winning both rooks
maybe is such a weird game
i don't know what's going on
okay i'll start with queen e6
i should probably take the rook
take the rook and then win the other
rook
this is so funny it's going to be so
black's going to have all the minor
pieces
assuming like bishop takes and then i'm
going to play an
f7 and i'll win the rook
so i'll basically have two rooks and two
[Music]
no three pawns so two rooks and three
pawns
for all of them minor pieces this is
like the weirdest material imbalance
okay except black plays this move
okay this move is actually this is uh
this should be winning now for white
because this is a thread and this is a
threat and this knight is still alive
so that could have
it could have been a lot more
complicated
but now now it's completely winning
because current position i'm up the
exchange and i'm winning more material
i should save the night
so it paid off i sacked
i sacked two bishops but somehow got
rewarded
let's protect the king
it's funny like in this position the
only piece
that has moved that is still on the
board is the knight
the rest of the pieces have just not
moved
whoa it's nicola thanks nicola
i appreciate that another thousand bits
shout out to nicola we have a nicola
command
and those so for those of you watching
in the future on youtube
i feel like this is this is a very
youtube worthy game so far
you guys should check out nicola on
twitch
okay let's go in for the the kill mainly
the kill of the the bishop
or the pawn so if bishop five i'll take
attack this and this
black still has a bishop hair
but i have the rook pair
just have to be a little bit careful
oh azrizev saying for everyone watching
on youtube you should check out eric on
twitch as well
yeah links will be in the description
oh no my rooks thankfully i have
i have this move
now the counter tactic
here's a cool idea king g6 knight e8
and then eventually rook g7 or just
winning the bishop
actually 98 with attack attacks both
bishops
so that move attacks my my rook
it's very very close to mating
so i'm calculating a crazy line 96
takes knight check king h4
knight check king goes back
knight g3
i'm not seeing it though i want to do it
let's do it
it should it should be good enough i
think at the very worst i
win the bishop it's so close to mating
i could play g3 here
g3 is maybe a little bit risky
i play this move
so attacking attacking both bishops
this is not the cleanest finish
this could be a kind of a funny finish
though like
it's so close to mating
oh that's a good move
let's take or no
i have to be careful not to get mated
myself
i check oh wait a minute
check here check oh the king escapes so
all right so let's take no let's
i'll take the bishop first
i'm too indecisive there
oh tricky
escaping the the diagonal
i'm still trying to orchestrate some
sort of like mating net
i guess now the plan is h3g4
yeah i don't think black and saw mates
if g4 then i i take
okay that was a really weird game but
thanks for the game
hue underscore jazz zero one
um what to make of that game
yeah don't try this at home kids
sacking both bishops it was cool though
like this is a mate threat
rook h6 was uh was resourceful
because it's easy to maybe a careless
play a move like this and just lose
i was thinking maybe black can take
um but i was really expecting
stockfish probably wants me to go for
the draw so i was expecting
uh something more like takes this this
this
this
and then i really don't know how to
evaluate this position
because there's no like we can count
material
but it's so hard to compare
two rooks um
i basically have three extra pawns maybe
losing one of them
to four minor pieces i'd imagine black's
probably better
but i'm not sure
so black's only slightly better
that's crazy oh i could still go for a
draw
but that would be
that wouldn't be the right decision
anyway um i'll probably put that on
youtube
youtube people hope you enjoyed that if
you're confused
leave a comment or question
and i'll see you in the future